To see why classification is so powerful and
so ubiquitous, and also to understand what exactly is classification,
let us go to our overall cognitive architecture for an intelligent agent.
This is a diagram that we have come across many, many times. Let us
imagine this particular Cognitive System is dealing with a set of percepts.
These percepts are in the world. So as an example this Cognitive System may see
some object, some animal when the Cognitive System goes to the zoo.
This might be an AI agent, or perhaps your friend who goes to the zoo.
And look at some animals and there are a large number of
percepts in that environment. Has wings, Has feathers, talons, beak and
so on. And for the simplicity let's assume that each of the percepts is binary,
it's either true or false. So either the animal has wings or doesn't have wings.
And depending upon the percepts and the combinations of this percepts one might
take different kind of actions. So if it's a friendly animal one might go and
pet it, if it's a unfriendly or dangerous animal one might run away from it.
So, all kind of actions are possible. Imagine that there are some M actions that
are possible. Send, we can again imagine that there is a binary choice here.
So, the total number of combinations of actions, as 2 to the power m.
So as an example. If I have a, if I see a dangerous animal in a zoo,
then I might both scream and run away. If I see a friendly animal,
I may approach the animal and make cooing noise to the animal. So, a number of
actions and combinations of actions are possible. And if n is the number of
percepts then I have 2 to the power n. Combinations of percepts possible. So
how is the challenge that the cognitive agent faces? The challenges,
that the number of percepts and the number of actions multiplied by the number
of combinations of percepts and the number of combinations of actions is very,
very large. And we have to map these percepts, combinations of percepts,
actions, combinations of actions. This is a very complex mapping. So
imagine that only 10 percepts. Image at environment, so I'm looking at
an animal and let's take 10 percepts that I'm paying attention to.
Then two to the power 10, the number of combination of percepts is 1024, and
doing it two to the power of 10 here because I'm assuming each percept has
a binary value. If I had 100 percepts, I was not looking at one animal, but
I was looking at a scene of animals. Then I may have 100 percepts,
in which case I have a much larger number of combinations. And
if I had something like 300 percepts, which is not very large number.
The number of combinations is, well it's a very large number.
more than the combinations of atoms in the universe. Now you and
I, and AI agents more generally. Are constantly faced with a complex environment
where there are a large number of percepts, and a large number of combinations
that are possible. So let's go back to something earlier that we had considered
in the class. We defined earlier that, one way of talking what intelligent agent
is to think in terms of how can an intelligent agent map percepts into actions.
Intelligence is, in part, a lot part perhaps, according to this definition,
about action selection. The other aspect of this is.
That if the number of perceptions is large and the number of actions is large.
Then the mapping between them becomes very large and very complicated quickly.
But intelligent agents have only finite resources. How is it then that we can
select the right action. Or at least most of the time select the right action.
Even when the environment is very complex. And do so in near real time.